Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday
morning podcast from Monday.
MMM.
What is it? June 18th, 2010. Yeah, I know.
I know. I know. I before
you even fucking start.
I know. I know. It's
Tuesday the 19th. I know.
Yeah.
Okay. What's the matter? You
don't know what happened?
Don't you follow me on Twitter?
Um,
I apologize for being a day late,
sort of, you know, I apologize.
That date to go really doesn't give a
shit or just banged your sister. Oh,
I didn't know. Oh, that
was your sister dude.
I didn't see a full like fucking
six months. She changed all right.
MMM,
no, I was doing, I was doing a
show in Chicago, Chicago and uh,
you know,
got out late and everything and not,
I didn't bring any of my shit with me,
so I was already going to do a
halfassed one. As far as the sound.
I was just going to record it on
my iPhone man. And, um, and then,
I don't know,
I ended up fucking going out until
like four 30 in the morning and then my
flight was at 12th. So you
do the math. Okay. I'm sorry.
I partied last, uh, Sunday
night. Like, you know,
like me and my friends
successfully robbed a casino,
you know, like in the end
of sexy beast, you know,
when they robbed it successful
and everybody's laughing
in a fucking, you know,
whatever,
some sort of old pub or steakhouse,
cigars, the whole damn thing. Just,
I was having a great time. I'm going,
I ain't gonna lie to you.
I completely forgot that I had to do
the podcast completely. 100% for God.
You know.
Sorry, it's not my fault.
I've been jet setting.
No, I had a great weekend.
I started off in San Jose.
I'm not trying to make you guys jealous
in San Jose, California right there.
You guys ought to just shut this whole
podcast off just out of pure envy.
You know, I don't know if you guys
are fans of the price is right,
but many times during the
showcase showdown, uh, one of the,
the will,
the final gifts to make one of those
housewives soccer moms lose their mind is
an all expense paid trip to
San Jose, California. Granted,
it is the first showcase.
It's not the second one.
Second one I think is to Fresno.
MMM.
Yeah. Went to San Jose and a,
it's slowly getting better.
Ooh, job. Things are going to get easier.
San Jose slowly turning it around.
Every time I come there
it's a little less scary,
or at least it feels a little less weird,
you know?
And then like Saturday is the weirdest
day when you work San Jose because San
Jose is one of those classic cities where,
um, you know, there's all kinds of
people until the end of the workday.
And the second the workday
ends like around five,
everybody just gets the fuck out of
town and then all of a sudden you can't,
you can't even get a God damn dinner
anywhere. Everything's closed.
Everybody's such close and like going
in those old fucking westerns when some
bad ass is coming to town and everybody's
pulling down their curtains closed for
business. That's basically what it
feels like. Um, but during the day,
there's people walking
around to beautiful city.
They got a little Choo Choo train that
goes up and down the driveway, you know,
and, um, it's just for people
who've never been to San Jose,
the people that I feel bad for that is
sitting somewhere in a job that they
don't like dreaming of going to San Jose,
California,
a little pictures of Sj as j town
or whatever the fuck they call it.
All around your little office cubicle.
Maybe,
maybe your workstation out in
the warehouse, maybe, maybe,
maybe you drive for a living. You got
those up on the dashboard, you know,
ways pounded down,
um,
Saturdays,
the weirdest day because nobody
comes in even during the day.
So you're walking around the city with
skyscrapers and there's literally nobody
there. You feel like you're
in the fucking walking dead.
It's the only way to describe it.
But, uh, but then at the Improv,
the shows were packed out. So I want
to thank everyone who came down. Um,
I worked with Kevin Shea, Kevin
Shay, if you guys haven't seen him,
he's fucking hilarious.
Totally original and hope you
guys realize that by the way.
And I don't bring any fucking
cupcakes on the road. You know,
some headliners, you know, they'll
go out and they go out with some,
some fucking weak person in front of
them just so they look even better.
That's not the way I do it.
All right?
I actually bring out somebody who's funny.
We'd be pat myself on the back now.
You know what it is. I can't
stand, I can't stand watch.
I can't withstand working with somebody.
Sucks. That's what it really is.
It really has nothing to do
with the crowd. All right,
let's get to the truth to this day.
You Go, it does. I can't, you know,
because when they,
when somebody sucks and having to
listen to that act five times during the
fucking week, um, I can't even tell
you what the hell it does to you.
And then they always end up
closing on the same fucking bit.
And I dunno. And the bits awful and it's
killing because they're, I don't know.
I don't know doing something.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
Some sort of standup trick and it
makes me hate them. So what I do is I,
I try to bury myself in the bowels of
the clubs so I don't have to hear a word
of their act.
But no matter how much I do that,
I still have to listen to
the last minute of their,
if their final joke cause I
have to be ready to go on.
So that's the real reason why I
do it. All right, so there you go.
So this is the fucking
podcast. It is a day late. Um,
and is always like,
don't
have enough fucking hours in the day.
I should just brought the stupid
God damn mics are on the road.
Where the fuck I didn't want to do it
cause it was too heavy fucking pussy. Um,
anyways, hey, I flew back from
Chicago and I watched that,
that John Carter from Mars
movie or whatever the hell
it's called, and he says,
I'm John Carter from Virginia like 90
times. And it was actually Psi Phi.
And I know recently on
the Joe Rogan experience,
I made fun of all those Scifi movies.
You know, if you're stuck on a plane,
it's not a bad movie,
you know,
you know what kills me is they always
got to do that shit in those fucking,
those Scifi movies where they always
have to throw in those fucking awful
invented words when somebody's arguing,
everybody's speaking English, you know,
speak in the goddamned king's English.
You understand what everybody's saying?
I mean, if you went back 300
years in this fucking country,
you wouldn't know what half the people
were talking about with all day. He,
this and that and fucking go
with and come with. It's like,
it'd be like reading the Bible. I can't
make fucking heads and tails, tails of it.
You know, read the Bible. It's like,
am I still supposed to be
going left to right here?
Do I go left right to left
cause it does, it makes, um,
they always have those dumb lines. Like
the gods of off guard will not have this.
They go out of the way
to like invent one word.
What did the name of
Marsupial is going on in here?
They had one of those and I actually
just fucking threw my headphones down.
Then the Douche sit next to me looked
over at me like what the fuck is your
problem?
And
I need you guys to come up with
a name for this phenomenon.
You ever been standing in a uh,
in an airport terminal and there's some
douche talking really loud on his cell
phone. Of course you
have. We all have, right?
Which is big does giant too.
There's a fat black dude from England,
so he sounds like he's in, you know,
lock stock in a smoking barrels,
whatever the fuck it's called.
And he's a tub of Shit,
which is making me laugh cause everybody
in Europe acts like they're fucking
smart and in shape.
You know,
he looked like the fucking dude on a,
you know, you know what he looked like?
You know that show, the Cleveland
Brown show, you know his son.
It's exactly what he looked like.
He didn't talk like him,
but he had the fucking round glasses,
the whole God damn thing.
That's what the fuck he looked like. And
he's talk and he's fucking, he's fees,
American fat. He Chicago fat. All right.
But he's European so he still has to wear
those tight fucking jeans. I Dunno why,
I dunno what it is about Europe and
fucking suffocate and your balls.
But Europeans just,
their genes cannot be fucking tight.
They just cannot be fucking tight enough.
They have,
they have to fucking frame their package
that God damn units look like fucking
Han Solo's face when he gets frozen in
that little piece of fucking carbon or
whatever the fuck it was. Um, anyways,
so he's running his stupid Yap. Yeah.
Mike going over to Mel bone after that,
going to go back over to
fucking who gives a fuck, right.
Just talk and talk and talk and big
stupid Chicago Bear fucking gut.
You know, you know, when you
get the creases on the side,
you could stick mail in there.
He's got those on the side, right?
Offensive Lineman, fat. You know,
he's got great footwork, dope,
but look at his fucking belly and he
says, run in his Goddamn Yap. You know,
so I walk away from the guy,
but he's one of these guys who takes
a little stroll when he walked.
So he keeps fucking walking over into
my little area, right? So I'm like, Eh,
you know, Bill, come out.
Just fucking, don't be this.
Don't be fucking screaming and
yelling. Just fucking relax. And uh,
what is the name of this phenomenon?
I start loading the fucking plane.
I get on the plane. He comes at fucking
Douche, right? Still talking. Yeah,
my yeah. Yeah. Good Day mate. Yeah,
yeah. All fucking bullshit. I know.
Good day mates from fucking Australia
before I get shit from fucking people from
England. Y'all sound
the same to me, right?
So he comes walking up the aisle,
he still running his fucking Yap and I'm
just going out. Jesus Christ. All right.
Only off, listen to this guy
for another five, four, three,
until he goes by and the motherfuckers
in my row, what are the arts?
You know, what are the fucking
odds? God Damn 70 fucking rose.
Not only is he in my row,
he's sitting right next to me and he
stays on the phone the whole fucking time.
Yeah. Night. Yeah. Now, now teddy bears,
watch intellij. Is this Stan
right? The whole fucking time.
Why he's waving.
I'm not swearing the whole fucking time.
Sit next to me running his god Damn
Yap at this fat fucking stomach and the
crease in the side. And um, it's the only,
this is the only a,
the only props I will give this guys is,
you know, he never seen, never said
hello. We didn't speak the whole flight.
I loved it. I loved that he
was in as self involved is I.
Um, and uh, last thing I
wanted to hear, I would,
last thing I wanted to do
was start talking to him
cause he already annoyed the
shit out of me.
And I know from experience that if I'm
going to talk to somebody from another
country, at some point they're
going to shit on the United States.
That's something that they like to do
while calling us the ignorant Americans
traveling around the world.
You know, all knees and elbows,
those motherfuckers come
over here and it's just,
you can't talk to him for more than
fucking five minutes before they, they,
they shit on America and I don't
want to fucking understand it.
You know? I would never do that. The only,
the only way I would do that is if
I was on stage in another country,
just just for the fucking ridiculousness
of it to start making fun of their
fucking country. But if I was sitting on
a plane, I would just be talking to you.
You have a beautiful country, blah,
blah, blah. I be a decent fucking guy.
Ah, fuck. Ah, Jesus Christ.
The hell was I just going to [inaudible]
remembered something in the middle of
that. The hell was I talking about? Hang
on a second. Let me think about this.
Oh yeah,
I remember what it was.
Did I tell this story like
fucking four months ago, uh,
pulled my big ass truck
into this small spot,
but there was nobody on the other side
of me and I was fine right when I came
out,
somebody had pulled in and it was really
tight as far as like on either side of
my truck. And then I didn't
have a lot of space to back out.
So it was his fucking problem. I keep
trying to back, you know, back out,
come back in, back out, like inch my way.
And so this fucking guy
starts helping me out.
I think he was from England and
he's like, uh, you know, next time,
why don't you do the
UNAMERICAN thing in back in
I fucking I.
Okay.
It's like you can't even help me out of
the spot without fucking nitpicking you
fucking cunt. You know what? I'll listen
to it from Australia, but England, the,
the amount of shit that is going on in
the world still because of those comments,
the fact that they actually fucking give,
he had the balls to give the United
States shit the very least be like, hey,
welcome to the party.
Welcome.
You guys are slowly catching up to us
historically as the biggest fucking
oppressive Douche bags on the planet.
You want to come at me like that?
Absolutely.
But if you're gonna fucking come at
me like you didn't do all this other
bullshit out there, the fucking caste
system in India and all that fucking crap.
The shit that happened in
Rwanda, you know, that's all.
I've got. Two examples. I
don't know anything else.
The Falkland Islands at Jesus,
the ignorant Americans strikes again,
but you know what I'm saying?
If I actually read,
I could fucking bury you guys
in this argument. All right.
With your jolly rancher flag,
whatever the fuck you call it. Um,
all right,
thank God I don't have a gig coming
up in England after that little thing,
you know. Oh Jesus. I go, Oh gee,
I've got a ton of shit for my
fucking comments about, um,
about hair metal last week. You know,
dude, I wasn't saying it was all bad,
but come on, this is what
I should say. Okay. Look,
disco music wasn't all bad.
Okay.
Okay. The freak. Come on. You really
think that's a bad fucking song
you do? Oh, really? In what? In
every rose has it's thorn is better.
You want to go back and forth?
Little tit for tat here.
Fucking the frig blows any of those
heavy metal ballads away. All right.
I'm not saying Van Halen with David
Lee Roth was to shit. All right.
It's kind of like the Red Sox with
Theo Epstein and Tito and all that.
Now that they blew it up,
we're going to be fucked.
Who else? What else was great in the,
there was a lot good fucking shit,
but there was, I'm just, you know
what the fuck I'm talking about?
Okay.
Gimme an R,
r o,
c.K and what do you got rock
and what are you going to do?
Rock?
You really?
Can you come up with a
disco song worse than that?
That's your challenge for this weekend.
If you can.
I will shut the fuck up about this
cause I'm not saying it was all bad.
I'm not saying I didn't like iron maiden.
I didn't say that. I didn't say that.
I didn't like Metallica,
which I actually didn't in the 80s.
I thought that it was too hard.
It was too hard for me. Okay.
I had to stay in my borderline hair metal,
little bit of Glam and uh oh,
he's wearing jeans on stage. He's,
he's breeze bringing it back.
Little fucking music box that I was in.
I missed out on a lot of good shit.
All that new wave shit.
Some of that stuff was good.
Some of the talking head stuff early on,
that was stuff was all good.
I missed out on all of them,
you know.
Okay.
I liked their mainstream shit burning
down the house. That's all I listened to.
Um, let me see here. If I can
get, Oh, what the hell is it?
Let me see if I can get any,
any comments of people telling me
all these people giving me
shit for my podcast being late.
Okay.
The fuck dude.
Hurry up with my free entertainment.
Somebody drew a picture of a big Dick.
That's nice.
Okay.
MMM.
Stop jerking off and give us the fucking
podcast for fuck sakes. By the way,
happy birthday. See what I do this. This
is my crowd. This is what I facilitate.
Oh, Jesus Christ. I can't find it anymore.
Okay.
Look for all you fucking metal heads
out there, all right. I wasn't saying,
you know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Okay.
You can't tell me that you don't watch
some of those old videos in it and, and,
and they're not fucking, I'm like,
I'm not. You know what? I'm not,
I'm not letting you suck me back into this
argument again. All right. I said what?
I had to say.
Okay.
There's a lot of motley Crue shit.
I did like some of the shit
didn't hold up so much.
Okay.
Do when that theater pain tour,
when they will go fucking coming
onstage looking like they sold Mary Kay
cosmetics. I mean, come on, I get it.
His fucking drum set when fucking
all the way around. But come on,
you can't tell me that even they
don't look at it. You know what?
Look at the fucking cover
of theater of pain. Okay.
I want you to hold that up and then think
about my argument and then still tell
me to go fuck myself. All right. And if
you can pull that off, I will. All right,
I will fuck off. All right. So anyways,
you're listening to the Monday
morning podcast. Everybody.
I do one of these every single week.
If you're, if you're new to the, uh,
the podcast is what I do. I shit on
things then people shit back on me.
And then maybe in the end of it
we, uh, we learned something.
We have learned shit on
this podcast. I haven't, we,
okay.
We've learned that debt sitting in a
cubicle is not something that you dreamed
up as a child and that you
eventually want to get out of it.
We've learned that I can't be funny
without saying fuck and content.
Every other word you guys. Uh, what else?
Yeah,
you know that I'm going to hell or I'm
going into the ground one or the other,
depending on whether
you're religious or not.
And you've also learned that there's
no reason to go to the post office. Oh,
he's slipping in a commercial.
Yeah.
Hey, listen, if you see, if you're
still going to the post office,
you're probably still listening to
a theater of pain on cassette tape.
What stamps.com you ask,
are you new to my podcast?
And you haven't heard this
commercial 40,000 times.
This is what stamps.com with stamps.com
is this wonderful websites that
eliminates you ever having to go
to the post office again. Okay?
Think about all the things that
happened when you go to the post office,
the homeless guy holding the door.
Like you can't open it yourself. Okay?
And maybe you're a liberal
and you want to give him some,
you're going to give him some money,
okay.
But you know damn well you're
not going to touch his hands.
So you got to do that little throw.
You've gotta do a little throat.
You know what I do is I always try to
throw it right at their fucking breast
plate, right. Their chest and that way
they can kind of do like a basket catch.
That's what I do, you know, because
I've tried to do the drop and thing.
They hand is so callous. It just
fucking, it bounces right off of it.
It's like you throw it against the fucking
concrete and it falls in the ground
and then they're crawling around trying
to fucking pick up a quarter and you
feel bad.
You know?
I would say about that time I gave
that homeless guy some change as I was
walking out of standup New York or
the upper west side in New York City,
I gave him some change. And, uh,
as I was walking away, I just
heard, fuck yeah. And I hear it,
hear the sound of my change being
thrown up with a fucking sidewalk.
It was an angry drunk, you know,
when he had his standards, it's like,
give me some cash. Oh, go
fuck yourself. And, um,
I remember half the day I get mad
and I think I laughed my ass off.
No,
I think I got mad because I was by myself.
So then it just kind of was him against
me so I got upset. But if I've, I've,
I was with somebody else,
I would have had the left cause they
would have been laughing at me anyway.
stamps.com everybody,
if you still go to the post office
to send out letters and packages,
the truth is you're wasting your
time. Okay. And take my advice.
Okay. You stamps.com instead. All right.
I send out all my DVDs is way send them
out to the clubs. I got my little scale.
I put on my little mister McPhee feely,
a speedy delivery hat,
cranked the whole damn thing out.
Slap the stamp on it and I'm done.
Never have to go to the post. stamps.com
is quick and easy way to get postage.
How does it work, Bill? I'll tell you,
you can buy and print official
US postage using what?
You already have your
own computer and printer.
They also give you a little digital
scale. My favorite thing, you know,
I feel like a little kindergartener
playing the post office,
except it's real man. Um, they give
you a little digital stale scale.
A stamps.com eliminates guesswork.
You'll get the exact postage
for any letter or package 24,
seven whenever you need it.
And the mailman comes and
picks it all up. You know,
unless you live in the city, right? When,
if you live in the city that,
that'll be a letter bill,
can you please not bring up
problems with the product? Um,
you'll never have to go to the
post office again. Endorsement. Um,
I'm so stupid. Uh, talk
about your use of stamps.com.
I already did that. So anyways, here we
go. I've got a special offer right now.
If you use my name bur
bur for the special offer,
you get a no risk trial plus $110 bonus
offer and includes the digital scale and
up to $55 in free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do
anything else, click on the radio
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburpeeyouarearethatstamps.com
enter
burr
and a welcome to the wonderful world of
never having to go to the post office
again. There you go. See what I just did?
It's like you would date and some psycho
chick and I just broke up with her for
you. You don't have to
ever deal with her again.
Now you can go find the love of your life.
You'll have time to do things like that.
Maybe get back into [inaudible].
You know,
maybe you could do that because you're
not standing in line at the post office.
There's all kinds of stuff you could do.
You could sit around and get fat if you
want it to. You know, I really like,
I just like printing stamps
after the post office is closed.
That's what I enjoy. That's
my big thing. I know, I know.
It's just a little thing in life.
It's just something that makes me smile.
Um, anyways, what else?
What are we going to,
oh Jesus.
But he can be a day late and you have
nothing to fucking talk about. Okay,
here we go.
Here's some more hair metal stuff.
A new rush album and God knows
rush was the king of hair metal.
You know, a lot of rush fans
won't, they won't admit to
that, but they had that, uh,
that awful period. Um, were they,
we're just teasing up their hair.
Remember that and had all the eyeliner
and those monsters they brought out on
stage was fucking horrible,
dude.
They never fucking did,
man. All right, Bill,
you're always saying how Neil Peart is
too mechanical of a drummer for your
tastes. I'm always saying he's a bass,
but I just like, I don't hear any,
I don't know. It just, it
doesn't get me. All right.
So anyway, I got a lot of balls.
Make Fun of the guy. You know,
I can play more with one hand than I could
dot four limbs and falling down a of
stairs. Anyways, on the new album,
the producer acting like a conductor
during the recordings to help drive live
emotion into his playing. Uh, the
drum parts were not as planned.
The album is really good and the Guitar
Solos are amazing. Go Fuck Yourself. Um,
yeah.
Okay.
Okay. I, I'll, I'll give
it a shot. You know,
I'm just not a, I was, I was never into
a, I just never was into that band.
Did I use Tom fires the mean mean
guy damn thing. Pick the bubble.
Pappadeaux MMM.
I didn't know.
I just never gotten into that shit.
Plus every time I would almost get into
this shit, like just something else,
they would do that. What would
annoy me. I was watching,
I was reading some sports article
one time and they interviewed Getty,
Getty Lee and a,
evidently he's a blue Jay fan and they
were playing the red sox and he sh he
made fun of Red Sox fans and I was just,
that was just a further fuck this guy.
Um, I dunno dude. Uh,
I like bottom better.
I like guys like Steve Jordan.
They don't play nearly as much,
but a lot of those guys,
it's very few of those guys that got of
those giant fucking drum sets that are,
um,
yeah,
that really blow me away. I actually, you
know who I liked his, uh, Simon Phillips,
he sat in with the WHO, um, on
that tour I went to in 1989,
you know,
thinking I was seeing the WHO and then
years later fucking pea towns and goes
when they had a new tour. Yeah. That, that
last toll mate, that wasn't the WHO, that,
that was the who on ice. And that
always pissed me off. It's like, really,
we didn't say that when I was buying
the fucking tickets. You can't,
why don't you go do some more research
on child pornography? Oh, Jesus. Bill.
MMM.
But he's fucking was unreal on that.
And uh,
okay.
I Dunno, I just recently just came
across one of his Solos and, uh,
it's not something that if
you're a younger drummer,
you're going to enjoy because you're
going to find the beginnings boring as he
builds his way up to it. But it's a, I
don't know, it has a beginning, middle,
and an end to the solo, which is I think
really fucking hard to do on drums.
And like I said, a lot of those
guys where they go, who's that?
Who's that other guy? Uh,
played with like dream theater.
A lot of guys go nuts about
him and Thomas Lang, like, uh,
those guys are incredible fucking players.
But after awhile I just, it's just,
everything's played at like 90
million miles an hour and a,
it gets fucking,
it all starts to sound the same.
That's the thing about speed. After a
while, it all fucking sounds to say,
which is the genius of
an Eddie van Halen to me,
because Eddie van Halen could play that
fast yet still could give me the chills
because he still had some sort of
feeling and soul underneath it.
And by the time the 80s came around,
everybody learned to do is tap on shit.
And then it just became,
who can play at the fastest?
And it was like an auctioneer, a
guitar after a while. And I just,
I'd never fucking
the fucking foot fucking 20 minutes
was that at every solo in the fucking
eighties. Every concert you went to,
they'd be like, then they
fucking slow it down, it
big, Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh,
Eh,
eh.
And then they look at the
crowd that the you like
and he's basically doing the same
lick over and over and over again.
He was just speeding it up
and slowing it down. Um,
and I think half the drum
solos with the same thing,
they'd slow it all the way down to just
like, you know, hits on the stair of drum,
Duh Duh, Duh. Yeah.
And then you'd stand up, put your fist
in the air and everyone would go nuts.
And then you would sit down and you
would just slowly speed it up again.
And then somebody would come out skipping
around and fucking kick their foot in
the air, and then they'd go
back into the sock. Right.
Oh, and the women dress like whores.
It was such a great fucking time.
It really was. And I got, I, you
know, I really never thought that.
I would see girls dress more
skanky than they did back then,
you know, with the fucking
ripped up pantyhose fishnet shit.
It was just, it was phenomenal
with the flash dance influenced.
So the fucking thing was always
fallen off this shoulder,
half a titty hanging out. It
was just, it was phenomenal man.
And uh, I dunno, going
out and fucking San Jose,
like the St these girls, I swear to
go with the fucking hookers shoes.
It's phenomenal. But, uh,
do we want to think about San Jose
on Friday and Saturday nights?
There is enough police presence there.
It's like they're anticipating
a fucking riot. It's unreal.
There's like,
they,
they have everything short of like
the helmets and the shields. Like,
I don't know what the fuck happened.
And every time I start thinking like,
Oh yeah,
San Jose is not a bad fucking place.
You come out there on a Friday or
Saturday night and there's like,
there's like 40 cops on
every block it seems. Um,
not in case something happens.
It's,
it's a vibe is more when something
happens and you just feel like the later
you're out. He just like,
oh, this is really fucking
stupid. I need to go back in.
I need to jump on that little electric
train that only go six blocks and get
back to my hotel. Hey, by the way,
they had something out there called
June teeth that I never heard of.
Can somebody please explain to me
somebody of African American heritage?
What exactly that is? Somebody said
that's when slaves were freed June teeth.
Why is it June?
Teenth why isn't it like one specific
day or did they fucking drag it out
between June 13th and June 19th?
You know,
is one last little fuck you like.
All right,
we're going to free up
some time in the teeth.
Hey Mr. White man. Fucking uh, June
13th. What do you say? Can I go now?
Uh,
while maybe tomorrow.
Just trying to get another four or five
days out of you. Is that what happened?
I don't fucking know. Um, all alright.
Fantasy beer league. Hey Bill,
you're starting a beer league hockey
team and you can pick any NHL or past or
present the NHL hockey player wouldn't
necessarily be in the prime of his
career, but something
close. Who Do you pick?
I think the inclination is to take someone
like Mario Lemieux but I think that'd
get boring as shit after a while.
Yeah, and you probably fucking get mad.
When I yanked on his Jersey and
threatened to retire, um, he goes,
I think I'd go with
someone like Rick Takut.
He can still dominate your league and
you can imagine drinking beers with them
afterwards. Exactly. You
answered your own question.
This is exactly why I would get,
I get fucking a,
yeah.
Who's that guy? Jesus. I'm so bad with
the names. The second season ends,
I can't remember anybody's name.
Who's The fucking guy?
He's on the rangers and said that
everybody gets my sloppy seconds.
Somebody like him,
somebody who can play and is funny.
You know,
I, I, you know something. What
about Carsello? I was soccer.
Cilla could actually play.
That guy can actually play the game,
can score goals and he could beat the
shit out of people, which he did. So,
you know, he's got great fucking
stories and he looks like he drinks.
I would definitely pick
somebody like that.
The last thing I would do was
get like as Sidney Crosby,
you know,
he just doesn't seem like you'd have
a pass the puck and a, you know,
when I accidentally tripped him,
if I ever got anywhere near him because
God knows I'd be like good trying to get
the puck, I would accidentally
trip m and uh, you know,
if he didn't get the call
or even he got the call,
he just get up and we'd do that shit
where he was shaking his head but not
looking at me with his
fucking a rosy lips.
Yeah.
Yeah. I think I, maybe I
go old school. I, you know,
Rick Middleton was always
a favorite of mine.
Nifty Mamie him maybe a Jay Miller,
some old school, tough
guys. Uh, Bob Probert,
God rest his soul if he was still around.
I get guys like that and maybe some goons
or something like that. Uh, all right.
I need some advice. Spill going for
it. Going for it. Oh Geez. Here we go.
Going forward. This is some guy in
from the 80 she's going to go forward.
That was one of the worst
fucking expressions ever
in the ADC. Remember that?
And it bottomed out in that rocky movie
in rocky three or maybe that started it
all when a clubber Lang
gotten his faces like,
oh bless you up. And then
Rocky's like, go for it.
And that was supposed to be like this
big moment. Like he's not scared anymore.
Go for it.
Did everybody that part of the 80s,
everybody in the early to
mid eight and promoter,
like the early eighties and
all those fucking movies,
everybody dress like they were on
their way to an aerobics class.
I, in fact, I think still
just the just alone.
Did he have on leg warmers during
part of his workouts in those movies?
I can't remember. Um,
dear bill, dear bill,
um,
since I was 12 years old,
I've been playing blues
music professionally around
the Colorado and a front
range area.
What the fuck is the front range area?
Is that Wyoming Bomba data,
but data?
Um, I've made good money. What kind of
gigs did you get in the front range area?
Every year?
I played blues music on Hitler's birthday
for this area in group slash
meth lab in fucking Casper,
Wyoming. Um, I've made good money and
lots of friends on the way this year.
I even made it to the finals at
the International Blues Challenge.
Needless to say, I've been
blessed so far in life. Yeah,
you must be a fucking beast
if you can do that. He says,
not bad for a 16 year old. Go Fuck
Yourself. You know, that's awesome.
For a 16 year old, Jesus
Christ, I wasn't doing shit.
They only I was doing was flunking
every class in high school. And, um,
I had my driver's light. I got my
driver's license to second, I turned 16.
This the second I was
eligible and I took it on a,
I actually took my, uh, had the
balls to take it with a stick shift.
It was a 78 Chevette for speed. And they
only reason why I say I had the balls.
Every car and my family, we always had
stick shifts. I don't know why. You know,
it was funny. We had, we had
manual transmission, but uh,
there wasn't a sports car to be found.
Uh,
anyways,
here's my problem.
Ever since I was eight years
old and saw a reservoir dogs,
I wanted to write and direct movies.
Now this isn't a choice
between my two two passions.
I do plan on doing both
for the rest of my life,
but with the screenplay competition,
I have little hope for.
Um, why do you have a little
hope in a screenplay competition?
They have shit like that, don't they? What
are you saying? You're not good, good,
good at it. I don't know, Bill,
why don't you read the rest of it?
You'll figure it out.
Um,
a screenplay competition I
have little help hope for.
Oh, I see. No, those do exist,
dude. I don't know where they are, but
they do exist. I remember Matt Damon,
uh, uh, Ben Affleck had
that project. Greenlight,
they're there. There's always people
doing stuff like that. I can't say always,
but there is shit like that.
Anyways,
at dad that's recovering from a
car accident. Sorry to hear that.
And a mom working to keep
our family in a home.
I have no idea how to start
making my first feature film.
Now you're probably thinking
you're 16. Um, no I'm not.
I'm thinking you're ahead
of the game this good. Uh,
but I have no money for the
high school like go to anymore.
And being in the blues world for so long,
I know that tomorrow I will wake up
and be 43 wondering if I accomplished
everything I wanted to.
Uh,
being a 16 year old blue blues musician
who is most likely isn't going to get a
high school diploma and wants to
make movies. Jesus Christ. Dude,
first thing I'll tell you is
you gotta you gotta fucking,
you've got to put a little sunshine
in your thoughts. They're uh,
they're a youngster. Uh, uh,
stop listening to that fucking blues
music making you just depressed.
Once you listen to a little hair metal,
it's happy. Um, anyways, I'm pretty lost.
It's scary because I'm at the place
where the things you do now affect your
future.
Any advice on how to keep positive as
I try and become a filmmaker would be
greatly appreciated. Thanks. And sorry for
writing so fucking much. Yeah, Dude, you,
uh, first of all, you're acting like
you're 86 and not 16. All right?
You're 16.
You're way ahead of the fucking game.
All right.
When I was 14, I was going to go to
Notre Dame and beat, become a lawyer.
By the time I was 16, I was thinking,
well, maybe I'll learn a trade. All right?
That's how quickly I fucking,
you know, went off the rails.
Now has a bunch of people in trades. So
what? I'm a moron if I can make the lab.
No, you're a fucking genius because you
can make a lip or whatever the flower,
the fuck that went. Um, this is how you
know how you learned to make movies, dude.
You just go ahead and
you fucking make one.
All right?
This is the deal. You don't have
any fucking money. All right?
So you could make enough money
like just playing music with a goddamn
bucket in front of you in downtown Denver.
Save up and get an iPhone if
you don't already have one.
All right?
You got an iPhone,
you can fucking shoot some video
then uploaded on and just, you know,
do it for nothing uploaded on the
computer, a friend's computer,
whoever you making the
movie with. Um, you just,
that's the way to learn how to do shit.
That's the advice I'll give you.
Just go out and you do shit and a in and
every time you think a negative thought
that say an,
I can't do this.
You have to fucking mentally beat
the shit out of that thought.
And you have to really become conscious
to have as to what your brain is telling
you.
You know,
because you seem like you're
in your very early on,
so I don't think it's going
to be that deep of a groove,
but your brain is like catastrophizing.
Okay. Everything you're
thinking of doing somehow it,
it ends with you slamming
into a brick wall. All right?
And if you think that way you
become paralyzed and you can't,
you can't step forward but you really,
your heart wants to step forward but
you can't cause your brain keeps fucking
showing you that brick wall.
So what's that going to happen is your
fucking heart is to be waking you up in
the middle of the night thinking thoughts
like what the fuck are you doing?
What the fuck are you doing?
And then you, then you know you,
you're going to start drinking and
it's going to be or whatever the fuck
something bad. It's not going to be
good because I'm going to be good.
Then it can become miserable.
And then you can see somebody young one
day who isn't in their way and you're
actually going to try to discourage them,
which is going to make you
feel like a piece of shit. So,
mmm.
The biggest thing I would work
on it is you just have to really,
you have to be conscious of
when your brain's telling
you you can't do something.
You 16 fucking years old, okay? You got
the whole, the whole, your whole world,
the whole fucking life in front
of you. And, uh, you know,
you can start making a movie tomorrow and,
and this is the great thing too.
You have just give yourself the
permission to suck. It's your first one.
It's supposed to suck. All right?
I had no idea how to do stand up.
I just signed up for an open mic and I
went on fucking stage and I hung on for
dear life. And you know what? I
sucked and I sucked for a while,
but every time I sucked a little bit
less and that's how you got to do it.
And I had all that negative shit
going on in my head. And, um,
I bought those fucking books
on how to think positive,
which was hilarious with my negative
mind is just as I'm reading it, uh,
wanting to absorb it, I'm also ripping
it apart saying this is bullshit. But,
um, I dunno, I, unless you're
like clinically depressed,
just negative thought is just
a habit you can get out of.
And that's kind of what I found. And you
just have to be conscious of it. And uh,
you know, it's really
just a choice. You know,
you just think a negative thought
and you're like, all right,
there's a negative thought. Step
back, look at it and be like, Oh,
do I want to fucking,
you know,
tie myself to that thing and have it
pulled me all the way down to the ground,
or am I going to say,
you know what,
fuck that thought and think something
positive. No, I'm gonna make, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna make a movie.
What I would do if I was you is I would,
I would just be thinking about guys
like Tarantino or spike Lee or a,
uh, Kevin Smith. Any of these
guys who just were like, fuck it,
I'm gonna make a movie.
And they just went out and did it.
And next thing you know that they,
they had a career.
Those guys can do what you can do.
That's just focus on them.
Um, yeah, that's what I do. Fuck it.
You know,
I'm a balding redhead in his fucking
business who has a nerve to try to go and
audition for movies every week.
What a fuck do I get off doing that?
Who wants to see that on screen?
You know,
but what do I think of people still
want to see at Harris? They don't care.
So fucking,
I'm going to look at Ed Harris.
I'm not going to fucking be focusing on
all these washboard middled full head,
a fucking hair run for
president looking fucking jaws.
Like I kill myself.
Jesus Christ.
Now I'm starting to depress me.
That's what I would do.
You want to make a movie? You Go
fucking make a movie. That's what you,
that's what I would do.
I don't why you feel like you're
not going to finish high school.
You could do that.
You know you can do it.
You know there's gotta be a way that
you can get a high school diploma. What?
What if you have to transfer you gotta
fucking transfer to a new school that's
cheaper. So what? You come in, all
of a sudden you're the new guy. Hey,
who the fuck is this guy? Right? You
come in like fucking clinics. What?
All of a sudden you getting blown by
some chick because she thinks you're
mysterious because you have a different
area code. It can happen just you know,
I was going to say by a trench coat,
but that's probably not good to do in
Colorado. Was it? Oh, that was a bad one.
Sorry. You know what I mean? This,
you got to think positive. All right?
If you keep thinking negative,
that shit's going to happen.
If you think positive and you do the work,
that's the critical part.
You'll be fine. And thus ends my little
self-help afterschool special here. Right.
All right. Don't write to them.
Don't, don't keep taking that shit.
I want to hear a few from
you in six months going,
hey, actually made the movie,
it didn't come out that bad. You're
going to learn a bunch of Shit, you know,
believe me and the, and that's the
kind of thing also that never ends.
I'm still learning shit.
Every time I go and tape a special,
there's always something. Ah, fuck.
You know, the first time when I did,
why do I do this?
It was the first time I was ever the guy
calling the shots and I forgot to tell
them that I needed a clock. I just
assumed that it was going to be there.
And I went out and there was no clock.
There was no way to tell how long.
I didn't know what time I went out and,
um,
ended up being a little bit of a
cluster fuck at the end of it. Um,
so then the next time I did a special,
I had a fucking clock, you know,
and uh, you know, I, I just
did another special, I learned
something on that and I,
and I was like, what the fuck? When
am I going to have this thing down?
There's always going to be obstacles. It's
just a, it's just basically how it is.
All right, so there we go. Now how about,
what do you say if I can find it? A little
bit of advertising at this point? Um,
game, fly.com everybody, do you
like playing video games? Well good.
I have a great website for your game,
fly.com right now you can try the new Max
Payne three ghost recon or the special
ops game. That sounds like one that
I would like. I love those games.
We get to go around just killing
people for as long as you want.
For the fraction of the cost of the game.
I'm game flight.com offers over
8,000 video games for playstation,
Xbox, uh, we, and now your PC.
Do you realize how insane
that is? Youngsters, please
don't take that for granted.
Do you know like back in
the day when I was a kid,
if you had an Atari and you had like 12
games, like people were jealous of you,
8,000 video games for playstation,
Xbox,
we and now your PC.
Um,
for my listeners only you get
free 15 days to disc offer a,
just give it a try. And if you
like it, you know, after 15 days,
if you like you to keep it, if you
don't, you can cancel it. It's free.
Everybody. Three 15 days,
8,000 games for free.
So my whiskey voice here, you know, you
can't beat that either. You want it,
you don't, are they doing that
down in the car dealership? Hey,
take this core vet out for 15 days.
The end of 15 days,
if you want to buy it, you can.
If not, just bring it back.
But until then it's free, including
the gas. They would never do that.
That would be insane. Well,
they're doing it@gamefly.com.
So go to [inaudible] Dot Com uh,
the podcast page.
You Click on the game,
fly banner or go to www dot
[inaudible] dot com slash burr uh,
for my, for special, for
special, my listeners,
what? Come on people I can't
read. For the love of God,
at least write it correctly.
gamefly.com/bar birth for a special,
my listeners only free 15
day to destroy route. Yeah,
that wasn't me. That was them. All right.
Did you guys understand
that by the end of it,
I was doing so well with that
copy to, you know. Um, all right,
let's get the last one out of the way.
So I can just be like a moron for the
rest of this site. amazon.com everybody.
All right. Do you go there?
Do you buy stuff? Both?
You think it to go in there rather than
going directly to amazon.com once again,
go to the podcast page on [inaudible] dot
com and click on the Amazon banner and
just, you know, buy whatever the hell you
want. Not Saying you got to buy anything,
but if you want to buy something,
if you go through my website to do it,
um, they're gonna kick me back
a little bit of that money.
And 10% of that goes to help,
uh, the wounded warriors project.
So you'll be supporting my podcast and
supporting the troops and it doesn't cost
you any extra money on amazon.com.
All it does is wear out your index joint
just a little bit more by having to
click two more times.
That's all it does.
So maybe someday when you're 90
and you go to point at some kid,
I shed get off my property and your
finger locks, you can blame me.
Okay. But until then,
you'll be, you'll be,
you'll be helping out my
podcasts and more importantly,
you'll be supporting the troops. And I
got to tell you, it's awesome. It's all,
it's been a great thing. You know,
I've been, I've been able to, uh,
send out a check to the wounded warriors
project, which makes me feel great.
It's just a great cause
and, uh, I've been doing it.
It just been rounded up to
the nearest hundred anyways,
and I'm actually thinking about, given,
you know, even more than that. Um,
God, Oh, come on. How do you, how do you
beat that project? You know? All right.
That's it. All right, let's
move on here. Um, advice.
Don't take shit from
anybody. Question Mark. Bill,
sometimes you and your podcast with go
fuck yourselves and don't take shit from
anyone. Well, let me tell you
my story. Back in November,
a cop pulled me over,
roughed me up,
was a huge asshole and wrote up
every rinky dinky ticket he could.
Okay.
Now, okay, now wait a
minute. What happened?
You were just down the street and
this guy just pulled you over.
I need a little bit of the backstory.
Here was this guy, did you know,
did he get into a big fight with his
wife and then took it out on you?
Or we did you say something wise
to the guy and he said, all right,
I'm not in the fucking mood anyways,
let's see if we could figure it out
here at the end of the altercation.
I shook his hand. Look him straight in
the eyes and gave him that look that says,
I will see you in court asshole.
I showed up in court this
Monday to defend myself.
My plan was to stand before that asshole
and having him explain his actions to
me in a court of law. Add, dude,
this ain't gonna work out unless she
had a witness. I wanted to ask him.
Even then,
that doesn't work out.
I wanted to ask them if twisting my arm
so much that I couldn't use it for a few
days was justified. I want to ask
him why he decided that me five,
six 175 pounds was a threat to him.
Six foot to six foot three 250
that he need to hit me from behind.
Um,
don't call me an Asshole,
but I'm not 100% buy in this story
because you didn't say what happened
before this.
This guy just did this.
Is this guy like the fucking
worst cop ever? I don't know.
Here we go. I wanted to,
I wanted to know why he needed to demean
me while I was handcuffed in the back
of the paddy wagon.
I then wanted to ask him
how many excessive force
complaints he had against him.
The answer is four. Oh
Shit. So I'm wrong here.
I wanted to ask him
how his marriage ended.
His ex wife has a restraining
order against him for
domestic violence. All right.
I tap out. You're right.
You're right. Sorry. Uh,
I wanted to ask him what part of
protect and serve did he not understand?
I want it to end the questioning with him
explaining how he got caught on a cell
phone camera assaulting a motorist.
You can look up the video on youtube
under Milwaukee Police Lambo driver l a m.
B o driver.
Here's what sucks in Milwaukee.
If the cop that wrote you the
ticket dis doesn't show up in court,
your case is dismissed and you don't
have to pay anything. We'll guess.
Guess why I told you that the piece
of shit didn't show up in court. Aww,
that's awful. I need
advice too. I let this
all be water under the bridge
or do I take this fucker down?
I really want justice, but I don't
want to be beaten by other cops.
What should I do?
Um,
well I think you just a shed some
light Milwaukee police, lambo driver.
All my listeners will probably
look up and watch that. Um,
now this guy sounds like a dangerous guy.
Look, you know, this is,
this is what I would do if I was
going to try to take this dude down.
What I would do is, you know what
the local news loves doing now.
They love showing like youtube videos
and they love talking about Twitter and
all that type of stuff because they're
desperately trying to get the kids and
people because they're losing
all this viewership to a, to the
Internet. So the fact that you,
you have this controversial thing,
you have this fucked up law and you
have a youtube video of this guy,
um, that makes, that's like one
of those perfect little pieces,
you know, coming up next Milwaukee
police officer or a little out of line,
check out the youtube video
that everybody's been talking
about all the Lord at.
Yeah, I mean, you could go that way. Uh,
but yeah, I mean you, you'd taken a a,
you're definitely going to
take a fucking risk. Um,
you know,
so you can heal.
Rodney King died this week and that
brought up that whole video and all that
type of shit. And I know, you
know, the guy just pulled over.
That's what you supposed
to do. I know. I mean,
they look at who's kitten know Rodney
King was going to get beat down no matter
what. I mean, if you've run
from the fucking cops, I
don't give a fuck who you are.
You got to get beat down.
But if you get back up,
you charge him a couple of times
absent fucking loopy. But you know,
there's gotta be a way to take a guy
down without giving them 12 fucking skull
fractures. You know what I'm
saying? It's a fighter. No,
it was, uh, it's, it's, it's
okay.
It's a fucking thankless job and
then it's a really dangerous job. If,
if the wrong kind of person gets a,
gets the job,
why did my phone just go off? Oh, that's
right. I got to do that ship. So, um,
I don't know. Personally, I can't, I can't
ever watch that Rodney King thing again.
That's like fucking,
it's the most brutal thing ever.
And actually when you watch that, now
you go, thank God they got fucking a,
okay.
What do you call those things? Taser.
What did he, what did we clear?
What do you call those things? What do
they call those things? They just, uh,
they Zappia did you guys
ever see that one? Um,
that one where they,
the cop.
Okay.
What the fuck do you call those
things? He got tased. He got fucking,
is it a taser? Cleo? Why am I so dumb? Ah,
fucking love this dog.
You know that Cleo, um,
underrated having a dog. It's the
best fucking thing ever. Anyways,
this I I to get you this youtube video
now that it brought it up, it's uh,
it's basically they're
doing a demonstration of
one of those fucking things.
Whatever the fuck you call them
that I just can't think of.
Why do I keep saying it's a taser?
I know it's not a he is it a taser?
He got tazed I can't fuck
it. I, my brain is mush.
So anyways, there's one cop
gonna Zap another cop to uh,
demonstrate it to the class and look,
man,
I don't give a fuck how
much of a man you are.
You get fucking Zap with electricity.
You're going to make a noise.
Most guys go like fucking go down. Uh, uh,
this guy fucking shoots it at the guy
and this sounds like he's like ending an
opera.
He gets tased.
He's like just fucking drunk.
He does literally something like that
and drops.
And I just love how the cop was shoot.
Some tries to act like he
just didn't scream out like
a little fucking girl, man.
It's hilarious. But, um, but getting
back to that, yeah, dude, that's,
that's a serious, um,
that's a serious thing.
And you and you, you know, if this
guy really is as bad as you're saying,
you know,
the right thing is not to let it go.
The right thing is to try and shed some
light on it and hopefully that they can
get this guy off the force because he's
given decent cops a bad name. They go,
so, but your, your
worries are definitely a,
you know,
valid.
I mean, considering none of those
cops during the Rodney King,
none of them got fucking, they got, they
got off. If you can get off doing that,
I mean, Jesus Christ, you know,
that dude who shot that kid on
that platform and in Oakland,
that was fucking brutal. He's
like, oh, I thought it was my, uh,
thought it was my house keys.
I didn't realize it was my gun
and he fucking got away with that.
I'm not trashing cops, I'm just saying,
not saying they're all fucking bad,
but I'm just saying, I mean it's,
it's practically fucking impossible.
MMM.
It literally,
even if you have video,
I think you have to have the combination
of having video and then you have to
be,
you have to be a certain level
of a wealth and influence
because if you're broke, you know, I don't
think that they're, that, you know, you,
there's no way they're just going to be
like, yeah, go fuck yourself. You're done.
You know? And then when you add racism
into it, I mean, you're pretty much,
it's pretty much game set match, which is
fucking unfortunate. So, um, I don't know.
I'm talking about society way
beyond my fucking intellect.
So I'm going to tap out here already
trashed fucking hair metal and I'm would
have fucking angry,
a psycho cops mad at me.
And then other people fucking think, I
dunno. I don't know what the fuck. Okay.
Response to having kids.
My kid is turning me into a queer.
Okay. Hey Bill, I listened to the
latest podcast like I always do.
I heard that you heard you start
to make a crack about having kids,
then catch yourself and say,
I hear it.
I hear it's the greatest
thing ever though. Uh,
I'm a total hard ass
attitude attitude wise.
At least I'm not a tough
guy. Bully piece of shit. Um,
all right, so you're, you're a ball
bureau ball breaking wise ass like me.
So anyways, I'll make this short so you
can read something more interesting.
I crack jokes, listened to rock
music and watch sports nonstop,
but my newborn son is querying me.
If he gives me one more
cute looker giggle,
it'll probably start a path to a
wardrobe of visors, khaki shorts,
braided leather belts,
and penny loafers with no socks.
I bet in a few years I'll probably raise
the pitch of my voice and at the end of
every, at the end of every question
I ask him. Um, well that's good.
That gives me hope. You sound like
an angry walled off emotional psycho.
And uh, this kid's making
you giggle. Honestly, sir,
when was the last time he giggled?
You know, that's when, you know,
you had a fucked up childhood is he
actually legitimately giggle and then it
makes you hate yourself and then you
actually, even when you're by yourself,
if you giggled,
you actually get embarrassed.
You literally to the point your
face gets a little flush. Uh,
like that's how much shame you carry for
actually having any sort of opinion on
any sort of emotion that isn't just
straight up. Go Fuck Yourself. Well,
let's go ahead, man. I'm
happy for you. Um, I hope,
I hope that happens to be
someday. I hope I'm, I'm, I'm a,
you know,
I dunno, mature enough at some point
to ever have a kid, a dilemma, a bill.
What would you choose
to either have sex with any woman
in the world? Nia wouldn't mind.
Okay.
I wouldn't care if she gave a shit.
If I,
my choice of any fucking woman in
the world just to do it one time.
Uh, that wouldn't be worth it. It
wouldn't be worth it to lose Nia. But,
but my Dick would override
that wisdom in the moment.
Um, or to have access to the truth
about any government secret in history.
What would you do? All right, well,
how would I know any
government secret in history?
What would they know that I knew it,
and then they'd start tracking me down
and then I'd have to be like fucking
Jason Bourne for the rest of my life.
Never getting to sleep more than
five seconds between concussions. Um,
all right. First of all, if I could
have sex with any woman in the world,
who would it be?
Okay.
Uh,
let's see here.
We got the k you got,
you got your major groups.
I think you've got four major groups. You
have famous, you have celebrity women.
Yeah.
MMM.
You have, uh, like celebrities,
like movie stars. Then you have,
you have a rockstar chicks,
sports checks,
and then he got chicks from your past.
You know,
some teacher you always wanted
to bang any woman in the world,
you're going to go back. But she
has to be as hot as she was. Oh,
this is a dilemma. Oh, by the way,
the other day I was at
a comedy club in that,
that a pink was dad was
actually in the crowd and uh,
I didn't go up or anybody, she
walked by it just fucking, absolutely
like slumped against the wall.
Beautiful. Absolutely fucking gorgeous.
Um, I'm telling you some of the, like,
those fucking like super famous people,
like they don't even look real when
they walk by. They just liked it.
That genetics, like, I don't know
what happened, but I'm just like,
Jesus fucking Christ, you know? I mean,
I knew she was good looking, right?
I've seen the videos, but everybody
looks good and videos, you know,
and then half the time you
seem it fucking real life.
I'll tell you this right now. If you
ever see pink, she does not disappoint.
Fucking just write down the checklist.
Absolutely fucking gorgeous.
You know, beautiful fucking dress.
That was sexy, but not slutty.
She had the fucking tattoos, but
not too many of them. Fucking,
just absolutely a fucking gorgeous.
I felt like I was in second grade.
Um,
you know,
like when a beautiful girl walks by
you like up the bid the day you'd have,
you don't even know what to say. Um,
all right. So let's get back to it.
So if I could
bag any woman in the fucking world.
Well, there's two kinds of women.
There's the woman that you,
you're fucking is absolutely gorgeous
and makes you believe in an afterlife.
And then there's the other girl you
want to bang just to shut her the fuck
Guthrie.
You know what I mean?
Like I bet there's a lot of liberals
out there that want to just bang and
culture, just stick their dick right in
her fucking mouth. You know what I mean?
But not like a totally malicious way.
Just really put one on her.
Was She just fucking
losing it and you know,
making noises in bed that she didn't
even know she could make and uh,
you know,
and make her be able to make those noises
even though she knows that you voted
for Obama. You know, there's
that kind of fucking right.
And then there's the other one
where you just want to fucking, uh,
you know, run down the beach,
hand in hand with some girl,
at least in my world, that's the only,
those are the only two. What would I do?
You know what?
I would choose a,
I would choose sex with any
woman in the world because, um,
that government learning
a government secret,
I've actually done that on a
certain level. And it just,
it's like being in show
business is when you're like,
wouldn't it be cool to meet this person?
And then you meet them and they're
like the biggest fucking asshole ever.
Or they, uh, I don't know. They just
like, they just do something that
okay.
Just, it just blows your whole
fucking image. It's, it's,
it's the wizard of Oz thing where you,
you don't want it,
you don't want to peek around the corner.
You don't want it.
You don't want to peek around the
corner. So what I would do is, uh,
okay.
I would definitely, I would, I would, I
would, I would have sex with some and,
and you know what, it would
have to be somebody famous. And,
uh,
then out of respect for Nia,
I would have to be a, just to shut
them the fuck up kind of woman.
Although I would love to run down the
beach, you know, why can't I have that?
Why can't I have happiness?
Yeah.
All right, let's, let's
pick one. One of each.
All right.
Yeah.
Is there any girl I just
wanted was a shut the fuck up.
Yeah.
I would say back in the day it would have
been Madonna, but like, she would just,
she was like beyond the noise. She
was so fucking annoying. She was like,
I would just want to get out of the room.
You know what I mean?
He always watches that blonde ambition
tour and there's nothing more nauseated
than watching somebody who's surrounded
by yes men. You know what I mean?
They're just completely fucking obnoxious.
Everything they say,
everyone's hanging all over every word
and they just laughing at everything.
Like that's, you know, something.
That's one thing that I have
learned in this business is, uh,
a major red flag is somebody who has
an entourage. If you have an entourage,
like a, I dunno, I've already, I,
I automatically judge you as like,
all right, this person is, uh,
is not somebody I'm going to want to
fucking be around because the only way I'm
going to be able to do exist is this.
I assimilate into your entourage and
when you tell the joke that isn't funny,
I can't be like,
I can't look at you like that joke sucks.
I have to fucking do like
what they're doing, you know,
laugh my ass off because you're paying
for my hotel room with the fuck Outta
here. Right. That and,
and people who don't hang out with peers,
you don't,
maybe they don't have an entourage,
but everybody,
they hang out with his fucking like
10 years behind them in this business.
Then that's another,
that's another red flag because then
nobody's calling you out on your shit.
Right. That's, that's how I look at it.
How did I get to that with this shit?
You know what, I'm going to have to
get back to you on this one. You know,
I'm a fucking 44 year old guy, so I don't
really sit, you know, when I was younger,
I had my, my, I'll go back in the
day, my list. Okay. When I was a kid,
uh, the bionic woman, all
three Charlie's angels,
uh, Farah, I wanted to
bang, I had lust for her,
Kate Jackson.
I would marry and Jaclyn Smith get out.
What's your fault for stand
in between the two of them
you're going down to?
But you know,
I didn't need Jaclyn Smith
because I already had the
Brunette with, with fucking,
uh, Kate Jax. Um,
then who else?
Who else in the 80s?
Okay.
I like what's her face,
the replacement for Shelley long.
Uh, who was in the look who's
talking, she came on had that horse,
smokey foresee fucking smokey voice,
whatever the fuck you thought to say.
It's supposed to sound way
more sexier than that. Uh,
she had nice fucking curves.
Got a little out of control there
after a while. But uh, you know, um,
she still has nice hair.
I got to tell you,
uh,
who else?
You know what's weird?
Florence Henderson,
when she had the worst mullet haircut
always turned me on more than when she had
that awful fucking, oh, Marsha.
Marsha Brady, when she fucking
had the little short skirts on.
Okay.
Fucking a Janet Jackson when
she was on a different strokes.
Who else?
Agile as it goes on for fucking ever.
I just can't remember anymore.
He's never Cindy Lopper
I could tell you that
she didn't seem like some
spazz little fucking boy to me.
Yeah. And then that fucking
haircut that she had was,
she fucking had like a tic Tac
toe board on the side of her head.
That just really freaked me out.
MMM.
Not that I was totally
against that here cook.
Cause I thought that chicken bow wow.
I thought she was hot.
MMM.
Ooh, fuck else. Did I like Lita
Ford. Oh my God. That I like her.
I think I might've somebody back dead.
I can't fucking remember.
MMM.
Anyways. Is that the podcast? Can
I end on possibly liking Lita Ford?
All right. If you had to bang any of
the runaways, who would your bank?
Uh,
I would've said Pat Benatar cause she
was the hardest. But just, you know,
knowing that she didn't really want
to do it, you know, I be to that,
that would be awful.
And we can tag team and other chick with
her. I don't fucking know. All right.
Listen, this is, I got shit to do.
This is the podcast for this week.
I apologize for it being Sadam late.
Um,
keep the emails coming and
I'll keep doing the podcast.
I guarantee you next week's podcast,
I will be doing Sunday nights,
so it's ready for Monday morning,
even on the east coast.
Just to make it up for you. This is my,
I apologize that I beat you last night.
All right, that's it. That's
a podcast. Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.